[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing why in the name of merlin's
beard albus dumbledore one of the most
celebrated and extraordinary wizards of
his time put on a cursed ring that
ultimately led to his death
let's begin with dumbledore's claims as
to how he ended up putting the ring on
he found it in the ancestral home of the
gaunt family just outside of little
hangleton the ring belonged to marvolo
gaunt a pureblood wizard descendant of
salazar sutherin whose family was a
member of the sacred 28
by all accounts not a great bunch anyway
dumbledore was hunting voldemort's
horcruxes and when he saw this
particular one he said he immediately
knew that set within the ring he had
found the deathly hallow that he had
always craved most the resurrection
stone of course dumbledore undoubtedly
knew the ring to be cursed as he knew
that it had been turned into a horcrux
by voldemort however he claims that in
his excitement over recovering the stone
at long last he quite forgot that it was
a most dangerous item indeed as he
explains to harry after his death but
the two catch up in limbo after another
short pause harry said you tried to use
the resurrection stone dumbledore nodded
when i discovered it after all those
years buried in the abandoned home of
the gaunts the hallow i had craved most
of all though in my youth i'd wanted it
for very different reasons i lost my
head harry i quite forgot that it was
now a horcrux that the ring was sure to
carry a curse i picked it up and i put
it on and for a second i imagined that i
was about to see ariana and my mother
and my father and to tell them how very
very sorry i was
now honestly are we supposed to believe
that one of the greatest wizards of all
time simply lost his head and foolishly
put on a cursed ring a ring he'd been
searching for because it was a horcrux
this just doesn't sit right with me how
could dumbledore dumbledore
have truly lost himself enough to go
through with putting the ring on his
finger i could understand forgetting
oneself at first seeing the item you've
been searching for your entire life
which for dumbledore was of course quite
a long time but to see it pick it up and
put it on i just don't see how he could
have been so beside himself that he
would get all the way to actually
wearing the ring i think this point is
further proven in the memories that
snape shares with harry before his death
particularly in the scene in which
severus helps dumbledore stench the
effects of the ring's curse
why said snape without preamble why did
you put on that ring it carries a curse
surely you realize that why even touch
it my volley quartz ring lay on the desk
before dumbledore it was cracked the
sword of gryffindor lay beside it if
only you had summoned me a little
earlier i might have been able to do
more buy you more time said snape
furiously snape cuts right to the point
here why didn't dumbledore summon him
sooner i guess you could argue that he
was delirious from the effects of the
cursed ring he was in pain and unable to
identify what he needed to do in order
to save himself but again dumbledore was
an extraordinary wizard one who was able
to defeat the gelat grindelwald and was
well on his way to undermining the
source of dark magic behind voldemort's
immortality he was powerful beyond
measure he was intelligent
surely he would have realized he needed
help and all right maybe he didn't want
severus to know that the ring was a
horcrux so he needed to destroy it with
the sword of gryffindor first but then
that only further shows that he was
sound enough of mind to carry out his
well-laid plans after putting on the
ring and being affected by the curse
so the question remains if dumbledore
knew what he was doing in putting on the
horcrux and letting its effect set in
just long enough to ultimately lead to
his death why in merlin's beard did he
put on that damn ring i guess you could
argue that he did it to save draco
malfoy's life and further push snape
into lord voldemort's inner circle of
death eaters after all it's one of the
first things he says to severus after
acknowledging that the effects of the
curse are incurable well really this
makes matters much more straightforward
i refer to the plan lord voldemort is
revolving around me his plan to have the
poor malfoy boy murder me but in my
opinion that seems like too small of
gain for sacrificing his own life no
offense to draco and severus so then
perhaps dumbledore was feeling guilty
about the fact that he had mentored
harry just to have him die in order to
defeat voldemort having come to know and
care for our dear boy harry as they were
nearing the end of their journey towards
overcoming the dark lord and harry's
inevitable self-sacrifice perhaps
dumbledore was feeling like he too
should make a sacrifice in the name of
the greater good
but again the gains from sacrificing
himself in this way seem too
insignificant at least to me in order
for that to be the real reason why he
put on the ring which brings us to my
theory on why dumbledore put it on i
think that after all those years of
lamenting the loss of parents and sister
and feeling terribly guilty for the part
he played in each of their deaths he was
ready and willing to face death himself
and join them in the afterlife to make
amends of course dumbledore could hardly
be blamed for the death of his father
percival dumbledore who died in azkaban
after being sent there for attacking a
group of young muggles however
percival's actions were a retaliation
for the attack on his daughter
dumbledore's sister ariana first of all
only went after the mughals after they
had traumatized ariana to the point that
suppressed her magic and became somewhat
dangerous herself
so it could be said that if albus had
been around to help protect his sister
from this attack his father may have
never gone to prison and his sister may
have gone on to be a normal witch but i
digress i do believe that he had certain
feelings of guilt for not being around
when ariana lost control of her magic
and accidentally killed their mother and
then he definitely felt responsible for
aryana's death which was the direct
result of an argument turned fight
between dumbledore and grindelwald as
young men abba forth too although he was
never quite sure who cast the spell that
killed her he certainly felt a profound
amount of guilt for the part he played
in her death if he had been more careful
around his family or if he hadn't been
so caught up in his pursuit of the
deathly hallows and the loss of his
freedom he could have prevented this
tragedy from happening
so when after all these years as an
older wizard he finally comes face to
face with the one magical item that
could reunite him with his loved ones he
would have us believe that he lost his
head and put the ring on if only to see
them one last time
but i think what truly happened was that
he saw the resurrection stone set in the
ring as a horcrux
lamented how much of a selfish fool he
had been in his youth and then in a
moment blaring of poetic justice he
chose to put the cursed ring on so that
he could join his family in the
afterlife and find forgiveness in death
perhaps after putting the ring on he
realizes that he could get a bit more
done and benefit from being terminally
ill as it were
so before the curse completely overtook
him he destroyed the horcrux and
summoned snape from there he was able to
kill multiple birds with one stone sorry
couldn't help myself anyways as i was
saying he was able to use his prolonged
death to help save malfoy further
entrench snape into voldemort's good
graces help harry get his hands on
another horcrux and ultimately reunite
himself with his deceased loved ones the
final reason being his one true
motivation behind putting on marvolo
gaunt's cursed ring this of course
brings us to the end of this video what
did you think did you agree with this
theory let me know your thoughts on this
one in the comments below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember do not
pity the dead harry pitied a living and
above all those who live without love
[Music]